would the Stargates be absolutely
useless considering the advanced
spaceship technology that the Towery now
have
hmm welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
a movie channel
[Music]
so I saw this video on another Stargate
Channel and I've put a link in the
description so please go over have a
check out of this video subscribe to him
um I really think it's quite a small
Channel at the moment but anything
Stargate related I really ask you guys
to go and check out and he asked the
question would the Stargate actually be
redundant considering how capable the
current Starships like the bc304 are
well
in that he has a really sensible
discussion but I disagree with him on a
few points
for one the Stargate network was built
by the Ancients so they could move
around the Galaxy quickly and simply
they built things like the puddle
jumpers so they could do shuttles
through now what good would the Stargate
be in the future resource G1 using it
for exploration well the Ancients
wouldn't have built it for that purpose
because they'd already explored them
they had to go there to be able to put
the Stargate down the first place we see
SG-1 using it for military purposes
going and actually fighting the gobble
world now using the Stargate for
military purposes is again a complete
waste of time if you actually consider
that to be a threat and this was
actually one big problem with sg1 that
they never really looked at but it
always kind of bothered me during the
series not that I really cared because I
love the series but it did bother me a
little bit that if you were on a planet
and you were the gold you know where the
Stargate is you know there's a threat in
sg1 why don't you build defenses around
each star game we put an iris in you
could do something different or just
build towers with loads of guns
why were the defenses and the military
options always so far away from Stargate
well they were so the story could happen
but actually in reality
the Stargate would be at the center of a
military base like Fort Knox is in the
middle of a military base
they would have guns trained on it at
all times they would have senses to know
when it was activated and when it was
activated they would send forces quickly
actually using the Stargate for military
purpose is again a complete waste of
time because you don't want the enemy to
know where you are when you're trying to
attack them but again this is not why
the Ancients built the Stargate and to
be fair most of the planets that the
SG-1 teams and other teams went to
weren't hard military targets they were
planets where we had been dumped by the
gobble world
so it's no good for military it wasn't
built for that it's no good for maybe
moving large items around the Galaxy for
say construction because again the
Stargate isn't big enough it's only just
over four meters wide the puddle jumper
just about fits through but that only
fits like what 10 people aboard so it's
no good for moving heavy Goods around
the Galaxy
but again that's not what the Ancients
built it for the Ancients did have
Starships now early in sg1 and this is
something that's discussed in the video
that's inspired me to do this it was
saved actually by Teal because if the
gold were going to attack the Earth it
would take anything up to a year for
them to get there but actually their
Starships traveling faster than light
were still relatively slow remembering
that the Galaxy is freaking enormous now
I've just done a video talking about
Stargate and talking about how fast the
actual bc304s were now they could travel
at
166.6 light years a day so they could
get between Stars within our galaxy very
very quickly and they could get to this
the Pegasus Galaxy which is three
million light years away in 18 days
so moving large objects around all of a
sudden becomes far easier on a Starship
imagine you're trying to build a new
city you need cranes and you need large
machines Etc you would have to design
all of those things to be able to fit
through the Stargate now they would get
there instantly but it would take quite
a long time can you imagine the train of
stuff just to get something like a crane
through just one however I bought a
Starship you can have very large objects
transported very quickly if you want to
move people around the Galaxy
instantaneously and very easily remember
it doesn't require massive amount of
energy to run the Stargate they were
able to run it from Cheyenne Mountain
very simply then Stargate technology is
perfect
you will need Starships for other things
but the Ancients had Starships for other
things you would need Starships for any
military action because as I said the
Stargate is not built for that and would
be useless at it but for moving around
quickly and easily moving smaller
objects remember in a shipping container
could go through the Stargate and you
could have a train of them
would again be very very simple and easy
to do and instant
again they make sense
so would the Stargate be redundant for
example in any new series no of course
not
but Starships go alongside the Stargate
system for a reason they complement each
other beautifully so the Stargate system
is perfect for what it was designed for
the Starships work perfectly for what
they're designed for any civilization
can project power and influence very
quickly on a galactic scale
and that's what the Ancients were doing
they were trying to influence things on
a galactic scale they were spreading
amongst the Stars they were creating
Empires amongst those Stars
really what you could argue is the goal
award when they
spread Humanity amongst the stars using
the chaparai
didn't really use it effectively they
became lazy they relied on the Stargate
technology and their limited hyperdrive
attacks far too much because they didn't
really care beyond living in their
opulent lifestyle
bye
is an occasion
you know that bitter taste in your
throat it's kind of wrapped around your
uvula
that's what's left of your pride it
didn't make sense that they didn't build
massive bases around every Stargate
assumes Atari turned up and started
causing problems well we'll just forget
that guys cancer comes to me what you
think is the Stargate kind of redundant
technology considering how fast the
Starships have become towards the end of
Stargate sg1 or actually do you agree
with me and that these are two
technologies that need to work hand in
hand with each other if you're trying to
influence an entire galaxy I would argue
yeah
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you're thinking
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
charge that really supports the channel
every month you can see them without the
adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]